on ABC Radio Darwin and the Northern
Territory this evening Australian story
according to the OECD international
testing Australian students are lagging
serious behind their peers in other
developed countries when it comes to
math but there is one man who is
determined to make a change he is one of
the most famous math teachers in
Australia if you don't know him his name
is Eddie whoo and he has become an
internet sensation when I was at uni
state to become a teacher I really want
research and articles about the nature
of intelligence this is graduating and
teaching freely while it hasn't thoughts
like that so I want to talk to you today
about where the intelligence is fixed or
fluid at the idea of fit intelligence is
there that there are basically smart
people basically dumb people and the
whole spectrum in between but whatever
you want you more or less pay that way
for your entire life
now educational researchers also zone
about six types of intelligence which
means that people are born with the
innate ability to understand some things
that not others and the idea of fixed
intelligence is that those abilities are
very hard to change fluid intelligence
on the other hand is all that the ideas
our intelligence can shift and change
not just suddenly but dramatically over
time and given different stimuli and
this idea has gotten a lot of currency
recently because of neurological
research that is showing the brain isn't
a physiologically static organ which is
what people brought up for a long time
now you might have heard of the term
neuroplasticity which refers to the
great ability to develop new pathways
and sinuses in response to certain
behaviors and environmental factors
now fluid intelligence I think is kind
of like this Disney approach to mental
mobility which is you know you can
become anything if you believe in
yourself fixed or fluid it is just one
of the many interesting topics that you
can watch on the website rutube it's
being created to help students initially
who had cancer but Eddie were discovered
that many many people wanted to be
involved with whoo tube
this afternoon on ABC radio down and the
Northern Territory your Australian story
star no less is Eddie whoo hello to you
how you going Louella great to be with
you
whoo tube 38 thousand subscribers and
attracting more than 3.7 million viewers
worldwide that's an extraordinary number
it's just shocking it's the kind of
number that makes your brain hurt even
as a math teacher and it's a bit
difficult to wrap your head around just
how many people now can have access to
anything they want to learn just through
you know the phone in their pocket it's
really quite astonishing chip the reason
why you wanted to start woo tube for
students for a student with cancer look
it was something that I wanted to do
really deeply because when I was at
school myself my mother was diagnosed
with cancer and as anyone can imagine or
as anyone's
experience it just sort of wreaked havoc
on my entire educational time and so I
knew what is like when your life just
gets turned upside down by health issues
so when I had a student in one of my
classes who was away from school for
treatment and then away from school for
recovery from his treatment I realized
that you just can't learn most subjects
like that but particularly mathematics
I'm sure a lot of people have had the
experience where they've learned
something they thought okay this all
makes sense but then they missed
something there was some idea whether
it's like timetables or algebra or when
they first started drawing graphs and
after that if you didn't get that piece
the rest of it was just
mystifying you know it might as all been
Greek - you actually might have been
literally Greek to you and so I knew
that it would be no help for the
students to say look off you go I'm
going to see you in seven weeks complete
chapter five six and when you come back
hopefully we can piece the knowledge
together I knew that wouldn't work so I
thought look my phone is not that bad
I'm just going to prop it up on the
table you can watch these videos you can
keep up with us while you're you know
away from us and that way you're
actually getting a very similar
classroom experience to what everyone
else is having
so ultimately what happened is with that
particular student they were able to
keep up and in the intervening period
more imported subscribing to your
YouTube well I think people for the
first time my own students who are still
in the class at the time they saw my
phone perched up there in this very
unusual way and thought what's what's
that about
and you know it's in pretty normal
experience you don't have to be you know
seriously ill to miss school to have
excursions or extracurricular activities
that take you away from class and pretty
rapidly people realize this is actually
something really valuable to us that we
can go back we can review stuff that we
learned a long time ago or any lesson
that we missed we can catch up and it
just sort of grew from there I mean
people say oh why would people will
spend time learning something like maths
and there's lots of entertaining stuff
on the internet I actually reckon that
people don't really dislike math so much
as they're just like feeling stupid you
know if there's any experience or
subject that you're learning it doesn't
make you feel very smart then you'll
gravitate away from that but if you have
access to something that can you know
give you the confidence and the
competence to be able to answer
questions and solve problems then people
want to get a hold of that and so I
think that's kind of how it spread
really far what's interesting about
spending some time with you this
afternoon Eddy is the passion in your
voice when it comes to maths and your
enthusiasm to want to share the joy of
maths with everybody and so when you
read about this oacd
international testing and the fact that
Australian students are lagging well
behind their peers in other developed
countries when it comes to mathematics
this is where your story comes to life
because it goes Divac then then this
initial idea that all your a math
teacher and you're just trying to teach
people because you actually at school
didn't like math yeah it definitely did
not come naturally to me that's for sure
I you know when we talk to you that clip
before about fixed and fluid mindsets
that's a very personal thing to me
because when I was going through school
I could do math I saw
got it but it just never I would sit in
a class I have this very clear memory of
the teachers standing at the front next
to the chalkboard explaining something
that was you know everyone around me was
just kind of nodding in this knowing way
and with the concept of the skill was
completely opaque to me and so I was
always the student who had to work and
sort of beat the textbook for hours to
try and gain insight and so it
definitely was not a sort of oh yeah
this is this is easy this is natural
I very much gravitated towards the
humanities English and history and drama
so I actually think that part of my
ability to teach maths comes from the
fact that I struggled you know I was I
was told once it's not hard for you to
teach what it was hard for you to learn
if you've put in lots of time and
thought to wrap your head around the
concept that doesn't just you know click
immediately for you then you've got a
lot more empathy for people who don't
understand and for people who it doesn't
come immediately to so yeah it's been a
long journey and it certainly wouldn't
be where I expected to find myself but I
love what I do and it's a great
privilege to help students understand
mathematics when you talk about that
idea if it's not it's not where you
expected to be that of course is because
you are an Asian background immigrants
growing up here in Australia and mum and
dad arriving here into the 70s having
high expectations that of course you
would go on to become a lawyer or a
doctor and I suspect becoming a teacher
wasn't what they envisaged for you
you're absolutely right I don't know if
there's anyone really who dreams of
their children growing up and becoming a
teacher it's certainly a job which is in
today's society in Australia is often
quite thankless I mean one of the things
that's made me very sad the further I
get into teaching is the more I meet
amazing educators who are so dedicated
who work behind the scenes long hours
before school after school during your
so-called school holidays I putting in
effort because they know it's worth it
for their students and it will make a
difference for their learning or for
their character but those people often
go by is on
heroes and never thanked never
recognised for their efforts and so for
me I think the fact that I you know
broader society including my parents
didn't understand the value of education
and out of teachers in particularly the
people who are driving education for me
in some ways that's driven me even more
to plunge myself into this profession
this vocation because you know a next
generation leader
they need the best educators and
education they can get so for me it's
absolutely worth it every single day
that I come to work I know that what I'm
doing makes a difference for actual
human beings who are standing right in
front of me and all the struggles are
worth it on ABC Radio Darwin and the
Northern Territory with you this
afternoon is Eddie Wu he is your
Australian story tonight on ABC telly at
8 o'clock and it is an extraordinary
story about Matt's and about how it can
create change and one way that Eddie has
done that is through this woo tube that
he created for one student who had
cancer and now it's gone on to have a
massive reach over three million people
it's extraordinary just how many people
are now watching it with this oacd
program for international student
assessment there was a test of 15 year
olds and it showed that Australia ranked
at 25th of 72 participating in these
sort of countries mathematics test and
that Australia is somewhere 28 months
behind its peers when you hear
statistics like that how they make you
feel I guess the first thing I'd have to
say is you know I am no official
statistician and I know that there's a
huge amount of information that's going
into these benchmarks these
international tests which is very
complicated and difficult to
disaggregate and unfold and so you know
there's a very broad picture which I
suppose can be alarming when you look at
it on the face of it but at the same
time you know because I'm in the
classroom and I know what students are
learning and I know what their needs are
from day to day I guess I I have my
concerns because yeah we've got lots of
lots of work to do we've got
a challenging task in front of us with
you know science technology engineering
math those STEM skills are becoming more
and more important every day but for me
I'm not worried I mean we've known for a
long time that mathematics and science
aren't easy there was this great article
that I read last year that was published
about students concept of what learning
these subjects is like and one of the
one of the headlines was mathematics is
science
popular until students realize they're
hard and for me to take students from
that point where they lack confidence
and view mathematics and science
together is something which is quite
intimidating for me it's a bit of a
launchpad
really it's an emphasis on the fact that
hey this matters it's not easy we need
our best people in the game and we need
to as teachers and as parents we need to
bring our AGame
I mean my children are three six and
eight and I very keenly sense the
challenge that they face with gaining a
sense of their own confidence with
dealing with these concepts that let's
remember you know most people maybe
don't actually realize that students and
the maths that they learn in sort of
your eight nine ten a lot of it was
viewed as really challenging difficult
concepts for even the best
mathematicians of the day up to say 300
years ago these are very difficult ideas
our brains didn't evolve to wrap our
heads around these abstract concepts
it's just it speaks to how far we've
come as a species so for me I just view
it as a challenge you know we have this
immense privilege to be able to take
crazy groundbreaking ideas that are
difficult to wrap your head around but
have so much value for humanity that
yeah you know this is just a wake-up
call for us to say to remind us this is
important this matters so it's
interesting that you talk about your
children and maths and imparting that to
them so I remember when I was in grade
four starting at a new school and we
were introduced to algebra by the math
teacher and I remember at the time just
looking at this initial contact going I
don't understand I don't I don't get it
I'm upset it's beyond me and I remember
that part of my brain I mean
grade four this is in the early 1980s
closing down and shutting down and I can
tell you right now in my mid-40s that I
don't understand maths I've never passed
a math test in my life and I have no
confidence at it and so then for me
trying to binge I and teach my
seven-year-old my nine year old my 10
year old about math it's a complete
mystery to me it's not something I want
to know about at all and so my question
to you right now Eddie whoo why should I
be interested in math what is the magic
for you because I don't get it sure I
can say two things for that firstly why
why should it matter to us well I think
there's a really practical reason which
is that you know just like a few
centuries ago it didn't matter whether
people were literate or not in fact very
few people were and then the printing
press was invented and it changed
everything you know our world was just
turned upside down by the ability to
speak and communicate with people far
far away through this amazing tool of
reading which is only accessible to a
very tiny subsection of the population
once upon a time but that's not true
anymore you know today literacy is a
basic expectation of functioning in
normal society and numeracy being able
to wrap your head around the numbers and
patterns and shapes that are all around
us the abilities just to read your your
bank mortgage statement and you know
make sure wait am I getting ripped off
or not making sure you can pay bills on
time making sure that when you go to the
shops you can understand you're getting
good deal these are just little
practical things which are just part of
the warping with everyday life so I
think the first answer that I have is
that today's society really requires us
to have a baseline understanding of
numerical concepts that wasn't true once
upon a time and I haven't even begun to
talk about all the technologies that we
rely upon you know how your credit card
goes over the internet and it stays
secure and you don't get sort of credit
card fraud how does that even happen
well an enormous amount of mathematics
is how it happens so I think that
there's that first practical reason
but there's a second thing which
actually speaks more deeply to me
personally which is that I guess I'd
compare it to music
you don't have to learn to understand
how music works you don't have to know
anything about rhythm or tone or how how
one piece of music is different to
another or how it sounds different when
one person sings at verses a different
artist but if you don't understand those
things then you're missing out a huge
part of what it is to be human you're
not able to access and appreciate a
whole range of different things that
make life richer and I guess an example
my favorite example that I love to think
of is when it rains and you know the the
water stops and the Sun comes out and
there's a beautiful rainbow in the sky I
think we often forget how amazing
rainbows are because they're just part
of reality so we're like well that's
normal why wouldn't it be but when you
think about it like if you were to tell
someone hey by the way after the rain
this is crazy
perfectly circular spectrum of colors
that's just sitting in the middle of the
air as if by magic that's a crazy idea
now my question and where mathematics
comes into this is why why is that there
and why is a rainbow perfectly round I
mean it's a semicircle if you look at it
from the ground but if you're up in the
air if you're lucky enough to be in a
plane when it happened you'll see it is
a perfect circle why is that how is it
that a million raindrops are conspiring
together to create this object of
immense beauty in the air and there's a
wonderful little piece of circle
geometry that tells us why now do you
need to know that well you don't need to
but when you do you can appreciate the
world in a much deeper and richer way
and I love that mathematics gives us
access to that Eddy whoo you are
conquering the seeds of math for me this
afternoon you are making it something
that I might even be able to justify to
with my old brain everyone can
everything from fixed to fluid I think
is the way you were talking about it
Blatter oh and it is certainly fodder
for the future this evening channeling
mr. woo it premieres on Australian story
eight o'clock this evening with Eddie
whoo it will make you want to get back
into math or at least think about it a
little bit more Eddie thank you so much
for sharing can't wait to see your story
tonight it's a great pleasure thanks
your time